the most valuable things that you can do
to move your career forward is to
network is to find people who are ahead
of you who can give you the steps and
say hey watch out for that puddle hey
watch out for that brick it's going to
fall and they can help you avoid because
the number one cost that you have to pay
down in your success is ignorance is
that you do not know what you do not
know if you not making a million dollars
a year whatever you make per year you
can subtract from a million dollars per
year and that amount is what it costs
you every year not knowing how to make a
million dollars that is the tax for your
ignorance it's the debt you have to pay
and one of the fastest way to pay down
that debt is to find someone who's ahead
of you